[Musik]
20 l Diesel pro Stunde kann so ein
drecker schon verbrauchen daran aber
haben die Landwirte quer durch
Deutschland heute nicht gespart in
Sternfahrten konvoys oder mit Blockaden
an
Autobahnauffahrten machen sie von heute
an klar was sie davon halten dass die
Bundesregierung die Subvention für
Agrardiesel kürzen will und es ist nicht
nur Protest es ist die offene
Konfrontation die Ampel müsse weg und
damit willkommen zu diesem ZDF
Spezial wenn man nur die Zahlen nimmt
dann geht es den Landwirten in
Deutschland so gut wie nie laut
Bauernverband endete das abgelaufene
Wirtschaftsjahr mit einem
Allzeithoch und doch hat die Branche mit
Wucht und Wut reagiert als klar wurde
die Ampel will ihr ans Geld rund 925 20
Millionen Euro Subventionen pro Jahr
sollten ursprünglich einkassiert werden
zwar ist die Regierung schon
zurückgerudert und doch hat sie da etwas
ausgelöst was sich um weit mehr als nur
den Diesel dreht die Bauern stellen die
Machtfrage und anderen Interessierten
kommt das sehr
gelegen schon morgens um 6 ist alles
dicht am kreuzmeerane in Sachsen ist
kein Durchkommen mehr über 100 Fahrzeuge
Traktoren LKWs Kleintransporter
blockieren die Auffahrt zur A4 und auch
die anliegende
Bundesstraße weil es immer in den Medien
heißt bauernprotest bauernprotest es
geht mittlerweile von allen Leuten hier
aus und weil einfach die Regierung
meiner Meinung nach unfähig ist dutzende
Handwerker Spediteure Kleinunternehmer
sind gekommen um sich dem Protest der
Landwirte anzuschließen jeder hier ist
unzufrieden das ist gesellschaftliches
Problem geworden wir haben kaum noch
Nachwuchs keiner will mehr den
Handwerksbetrieb ausführen weil wird
nicht bezahlt in der Industrie gibt's
mehr Geld und wir können die die Preise
nicht halten weil die Kunden uns das
nicht mehr bezahlen es ist ein diffuses
protestgemisch das sich heute an so
vielen Orten in Deutschland zeigt in
Berlin sind die Landwirte fast in der
Minderheit es eint die Wut auf die
Regierung ich denke nicht dass wir jetzt
hier instrumentalisiert werden
weil letztendlich ja auch jeder egal be
rechts oder links ist ja trotzdem eine
Meinung vertreten kann und sagen kann
ich möchte nicht dass sie die
Lebensmittelpreise ins Unendliche
steigen und ich möchte auch nicht dass
die Inflation weiter steigt und das sind
ja gemeinenanliegen die ja jeder hat
irgendwo ne in Dresden werden die
bauernproteste vereinnahmt und zwar von
den Rechtsextremen freien Sachsen von
der AFD und von anderen Gruppierungen
mehrere tausend Menschen am Mittag durch
die
Innenstadt wenn ich auf bauernplakaten
den Galgen sehe das sind
rechtspopulistische Proteste und ich
glaube die Akzeptanz der Bürger war am
Anfang hoch gegenüber den
bauernblockaden und auch gegenüber den
Protesten wenn sich aber diese Kräfte
durchsetzen und da gibt es ja durchaus
Anzeichen dann dürfte die Akzeptanz in
der Bevölkerung auch zurückgehen auch in
München haben mehr als 8000 Menschen
gegen die Politik der Bundesregierung
ert Handwerker und Landwirte Hand in
Hand seit an
seit gerade im Moment die explodieren
halt auch diese Preise so und der
normale Handwerker der kann sich leben
hier in dieser Gegend tatsächlich nicht
leisten die Unzufriedenheit bei vielen
ist groß der heutige Montag war nur der
Auftakt einer deutschlandweiten
Protestwoche in sbrücken begrüße ich die
SPD Ministerpräsidentin des Saarlandes
guten Abend Frau relinge ein schön guten
Abend sie fordern wie auch ihre
Parteikollegen aus Brandenburg
mecklenburg- Vorpommern und
Niedersachsen von der Bundesregierung
die Kürzungen komplett zurückzunehmen
warum fallen sie ihrem SPD-Kanzler in
den Rücken na ich glaube die
Bundesregierung hat ja selbst erkannt
dass der erste Vorschlag der gemacht
worden ist nicht ganz fair war denn die
Bauern können im Grunde genommen nicht
darauf reagieren weil es eben keine
Alternative im Moment gibt und deshalb
war es richtig jetzt zumindest mal einen
Kompromissvorschlag zu machen ich habe
gesagt am besten ist natürlich wenn der
Vorschlag wieder ganz vom Tisch genommen
wird aber zumindest müssen wir über
Alternativen reden mit dem Berufsstand
die dazu führen dass es eben nicht zu
einer über Förderung auch kommt dass
sich keiner überfordert fühlt denn das
ist gerade im Moment der Fall es ist
eigentlich nur der Tropfen der jetzt
noch mal das fast zum Überlaufen
gebracht hat deshalb ist das eine
Debatte aber ich glaube wir haben auch
noch eine ganze Reihe ander Debatten in
der Landwirtschaft wenn es darum dazu
aber bleiben wir bei dem Punkt Frau
regenl die Ampel steht ohnehin im
Kreuzfeuer auch recht versucht wir haben
es gesehen die Situation auszunutzen und
die Stimmung weiter aufzuheizen wie
gefährlich ist das das macht mir schon
ein bisschen Sorge wie die Debatte
gerade geführt wird und deshalb müssen
wir abschichten wir können nicht alle
schwierigen Diskussionen die gerade in
Deutschland zu führen sind und das sind
nicht ganz wenige mit denen wir es hier
zu tun haben in einen Topf werfen und
kräftig rumrühren wenn es jetzt um die
Belange der Bauern geht müssen wir
einfach mal auch glaube ich die Debatte
damit beginnen dass wir unseren Respekt
dafür zum Ausdruck bringen was dort an
Leistung gebracht wird denn das ist
etwas was auch vermisst wird neben den
finanziellen Belastungen aber wir können
uns auch nicht gegenseitig niederprüllen
die Lautstärke darf nicht über das
Gewicht der Argumente entscheiden und
das macht mir schon ein bisschen Sorge
denn es wird immer lauter und wie
Bereitschaft miteinander über gute
Lösungen zu reden sie scheint ein Stück
weit abzunehmen mal an die eigene Nase
gefasst welchen Anteil hat die Ampel
denn selbst daran dass die Proteste so
scharf sind und der Ton der Art gereizt
ist na ich glaube wir müssen schon
festhalten dass es in der Bundesrepublik
noch nie so viele so heftige Krisen
gleichzeitig gegeben hat wie wir das
jetzt gerade im Moment erleben und da
ist das nicht ganz einfach immer zum
richtigen Zeitpunkt die richtige
Kommunikation auch zu den richtigen
Entscheidungen zu haben aber an dieser
Stelle ist ja deutlich geworden man ist
auch bereit Entscheidungen zu
korrigieren das ist glaube ich schon ein
wichtiges Signal und das sollte man auch
genauso aufgreifen und in diesen Sinne
eben miteinander weitermachen und an den
Sachthemen diskutieren ich danke ja auch
dem Bauernverband dass er deutlich
gemacht hat dass er sich eben nicht
vereinnahmen lassen will von
Trittbrettfahrern die eigentlich den
Anliegen der Landwirte auch nur ein
Bärendienst erweisen indem es Ihnen gar
nicht um die Sache geht wenn sie jetzt
sagen alle geplanten Kürzungen müssen
wieder vom Tisch dann heißt das wer
protestiert bekommt Recht ist das
politisch klug oder doch eher
populistisch das geht in der Tat nicht
darum dass derjenige Recht bekommt der
am lautesten
ruft aber es geht vor allem um
Planbarkeit und Verlässlichkeit und mit
der Entscheidung die Subventionierung
quasi sofort und gleich einzustellen
haben wir eben einen Punkt erreicht wo
es nicht planbar und nicht verlässlich
ist und es auch keine Alternative für
die Landwirte gibt noch nicht und
deshalb ist es glaube ich klug einen Weg
zu beschreiben wie wir mit Innovationen
es auch hinbekommen dass auch der CO2
Ausstoß in der Landwirtschaft weiter
zurückgehen kann dass wir über das Thema
Bürokratie auch sprechen wo sich auch
viele ganz abseits von finanziellen
Fragen einfach auch überfordert fühlen
und wo wir auch deutlich machen dass die
Subventionen keine Almosen sind sondern
dass es der Preis ist den die
Gesellschaft bereit ist zu zahlen dafür
dass wir hohe Standards in der
Tierhaltung aber auch im Klimaschutz und
im Naturschutz einhalten wollen ich
glaube mehr Respekt in der Debatte neben
allen finanziellen Fragen kann schon
sehr viel weiterhelfen und das ist
glaube ich auch die Chance die jetzt dar
steckt dass so viel Aufmerksamkeit auf
dem Thema liegt ja danke für Ihre sich
derdinke Anke relinger SPD
Ministerpräsidentin des Saarlandes danke
schön einer von denen die heute
protestiert haben ist Erich gussen er
ist Landwirt aus Jülich und mit extremen
Gesinnungen hat er nichts am Hut viel
mehr ärgert er sich schon länger über
all das was aus seiner Sicht ihm und
dieser Branche zugemutet wird
Investitionen für den Klimaschutz
Bürokratie Vorgaben aus Brüssel und
jetzt auch noch die Sparpläne wir waren
bei ihm und haben uns mal vorrechnen
lassen wie ihm das zu Buche schlägt
Erich gussen bereitet heute schon das
nächste Plakat vor für die nächste
Protestaktion morgen Abend im Rheinland
74 Hektar Ackerbau bewirtschaftet der
landwird die ursprünglichen
Kürzungspläne der Bundesregierung hätten
ihn rund 7000 € im Jahr gekostet die
Koalition ruderte zurück aber eben nur
teilweise aber die agrardieselvergütung
soll ja komplett gestrichen werden auch
wenn es über z Jahre ist aber sie fällt
komplett weg und das macht dann aber
doch mal die Hälfte dann aus also
3in5000 € und dann stehen ja noch 100
Millionen Euro im Agrarhaushalt drin die
gekürzt werden sollen da wiss man ja
noch gar nicht wo das passiert das wird
uns natürlich auch noch mal treffen das
fehlende Geld ist das eine doch auch die
aus Sicht von bauergussen übertrieben
strengen Vorschriften machen die
Landwirte sauer Stichwort
Überregulierung zu viele Regeln und
Auflagen für die deutschen Landwirte um
auf einem internationalen Markt
konkurrenzfähig zu bleiben das sieht man
jetzt beim Pflanzenschutz wieder was da
überlegt worden ist aber auch bei
naturschutzgesetzgebungen das kann man
vieles aufzählen und dann kommt noch die
Sache wir haben als einziger
Wirtschaftszweig ja die Reduzierung von
CO2 Klimagasen eingehalten und jetzt
werden wir dafür auch noch bestraft
indem wir da mehr für bezahlen sollen
und die Industriebetriebe sollen
demnächsten verbilligten Strompreis
bekommen und das hat das fast zum
Überlaufen gebracht und das geht einfach
nicht mit den europäischen Konkurrenten
können deutsche Landwirte wie Erich
gussen kaum noch mithalten in Frankreich
z.B dürfen die Kollegen billiges Heizöl
tanken und hier zu Lande wird der
Mindestlohn angehoben damit steigen die
Lohnkosten lange Zeit hatte sich Erich
gussen mit seinem Unmut zurückgehalten
hatte immer wieder den Versprechungen
aus Berlin geglaubt damit ist jetzt
Schluss alle Politiker sagen wir wollen
die kleinen Betriebe unterstützen aber
genau das wird jetzt nicht gemacht
sondern viele Jugendliche sagen sie
sehen keine Zukunft mehr in dem ganzen
für er gussen geht es um die Existenz
eines ganzen Berufszweigs um die Zukunft
der Agrarwirtschaft in Deutschland darum
wird er weiter
protestieren zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt
Professor Alfons balmann vom Leipnitz
Institut für agrarentwicklung in
transformationsökonomien in Halle guten
Abend guten Abend wie ökonomisch ist es
Subventionen für die Landwirtschaft
abzubauen es geht bei der Streichung der
Diesel Beihilfe um die Streichung einer
längst über flüssigen Subvention sie ist
schon seit langem nicht mehr gut
begründet aber das größere Problem ist
die Landwirtschaft ist insgesamt von
vielen Subventionen abhängig und man
macht sich sicherlich auch sorgen dass
das sozusagen erst der erste Schritt ist
bevor weitere Subventionen dann auch
gestrichen werden J Mann also aus ihrer
Sicht die Bauern auf hohem Niveau
Verbandspräsident rugwit spricht von
einem sterben auf
Raten äh das ist äh Unsinn was er
behauptet aber natürlich wir haben in
der Landwirtschaft sowohl sehr
erfolgreiche Betriebe die auch
überdurchschnittlich groß sind die
bekommen auch den größten Batzen von den
Agrardiesel Subventionen und wir haben
da auf der anderen Seite sehr viele
kleinere Betriebe die
unterdurchschnittlich partizipieren
selbst von diesen Subventionen
allerdings sind viele dieser Betriebe
ohnehin schon seit langen nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig und die Frage ist
natürlich wenn man wirklich die
Landwirtschaft in Deutschland verändern
will wo sollte man die Prioritäten
setzen sollte man weiter Strukturen
konservieren die mit verantwortlich
dafür sind dass viele Betriebe
unrentabel sind oder sollte man darauf
hinauswirken dass die Landwirtschaft
insgesamt leistungsfähiger produktiver
wettbewerbsfähiger wird und dann auch in
der Lage ist
subsventionskürzungen hinzunehmen wir
haben be gesehen es gibt ja viele
Faktoren in dieser Rechnung sie sagen es
die Größe eines Betriebs ob es um Tiere
geht oder Getreide oder Obst die
internationale Konkurrenz wie steht's
denn um die deutschen Subventionen im
sagen wir mal europäischen
Vergleich dieser internationale
Vergleich macht aus meiner Sicht relativ
wenig Sinn er lenngt von den
eigentlichen Problemen ab genauso könnte
man argumentieren dass
Landwirte benachteiligt sind wenn sie
auf schlechteren Böden äh wirtschaften
und äh darüber diskutieren wir zurecht
auch nicht die eigentliche Konkurrenz in
der Landwirtschaft findet vor Ort statt
zwischen den einzelnen
landwirtschaftlichen Betrieben die sich
im gegen im Regelfall gegenseitig die
Preise für Pachtflächen beispielsweise
hoch konkurrieren und dadurch ihre
Produktionskosten wesentlich stärker
steigern als dadurch dass jetzt etwa 30
€ pro Hektar an dieselbeihihilfe
gestrichen wird Professor Alf bmann
vielen Dank für diese
Information schon morgen sollen die
Proteste weitergehen die ganze Woche
noch auf den verstopften Straßen kann
dann jeder zeigen wie solidarisch er
oder sie zur hiesigen Landwirtschaft
steht und im Supermarkt wenn es darum
geht vielleicht nicht immer nur das
billigste Produkt zu kaufen
auch damit verabschieden wir uns gleich
im Anschluss senden wir zum Tode von
Franz Beckenbauer die Dokumentation
Triumphe Affären und Skandale auf wieder
[Musik]